let's talk about basically the hottest
thing on the internet as sad as that may
be miss amanda bynes you know when i
started doing the show the whole point
was not to do these like trivial
nonsensical pop-culture things but this
is the type of thing that is kind of
jumped into mainstream and I think we
can kind of make it a bigger a bigger
topic so she was a child actress she was
on Nickelodeon she was on right
Nickelodeon she was in that movie she's
the man I actually thought that was kind
of cute and basically she's gone bonkers
she's sending out these crazy tweets you
guys have all heard about this stuff she
may have thrown a bong out her window
and got arrested last week so my first
question you know what let's show let's
show some some of her stuff and then
we'll go from there
so that's her at her court hearing last
week I believe that might be a wig I'm
not 100% sure let's look at a couple of
the tweets I want at Drake to murder my
vagina all right yeah I have a feeling
you'll both have some ideas on that I
think we have one more where we got a
couple more here
Rihanna no one wants to be your lover so
you can call everyone and their mother
that I almost named my do new dog
Rihanna was that supposed to rhyme I
read it as if it was gonna rhyme I don't
know Rihanna Chris Brown beat you
because you're not pretty enough and
Rihanna you look so ugly trying to be
white I did not know that Rihanna was
trying to be white okay so where do we
start here do we think this is all real
even or is this just like somebody
trying to hang on to their last little
bit of famine
I think it's fake I think the amanda
bynes twitter is fake i think whatever
is going on with her in the real world
is it's real and those pictures are
stolen weight from whatever sure real
thing her twitter is not verified let's
throw that out okay so that's true the
Twitter there is no blue check now yeah
famous blue check it is not on
on there so you think it literally is
not her I don't think that Twitter is
heart now I just think that the the
correlation that's going between the
tweets and like let's say that image of
her in the courtroom seems to have a
pretty um you know positive correlation
there's yeah you think there's some
connection you really just don't want to
believe it collision love her so much
yeah I grew up watching her she was one
of my idols and to see this happen I'm
just like no it's not her
yeah denial of yours is that you're an
Amanda Bynes tonight
what is our fascination with watching
it's always girls we seem to have a
thing about girls throwing themselves so
Britain Bieber I'm sorry oh right now
it's Charlie Sheen good one right but
Charlie Sheen is an adult man so he's
still an adult there something about
teen girls we let you know so Britney
and Lindsay Lohan you know even if
they're young 20s let's say we love
watching them the trends those adult men
and Justin Bieber who I think may be a
teen girl
so that is chair the Cory the Cory yeah
yeah one of them literally destroyed
himself and the other one yeah yeah
that's true
um but what is it about girls I think or
this teen girl thing I mean I think it's
just we have a fascination with the
media in general so when you get to
something you know people have this you
know kind of car wreck fascination they
want to in a way see this kind of demise
unfold you know and it's like it's how
we why we turn into tune in so so deeply
- you know when disasters strike the
world it could be an area that you've
never even heard of but you're so you
know indebted to it you're so invested
into that situation because people are
just fascinated with that other and you
know they don't know what to expect and
it's it's why people are so into reality
television I think you know it's like
you don't know - expectance really
happening you can't write this stuff
yeah like you can if you wrote what he
was doing it would be like this is the
most ridiculous thing I've ever this
would never happen yeah but she look
she's legitimately standing in court
with one of its 90% wits like she she
was like let me find the worst wig that
I could find right what happened some
oh right it started to fall out because
of over processing so she shaved her
entire head now she's wearing a wig
nonetheless the wig is a bit over the
top you could get something a little
more demure right exactly and not now
with the whole even this morning I don't
know if you've heard there's a new
attack on Twitter with Chrissy Teigen
she's a Sports Illustrated model I guess
and for some reason she keeps using the
word ugly and in my adulthood and yours
I mean had you ever use the word ugly
it's not raining on the playground again
yeah like it's like she should like kick
their shin I'm like run away after yeah
do you think there's something we as
someone that sympathizes with a young
amanda bynes do you think there's
something like I think the only thing we
could probably do to help her would be
ignore her like for me like I have
officially sworn off I never tweet about
the Kardashians anymore because to me
that's the only way we can stop them you
know I mean we can't keep feeding it is
there any fashion
I'd anything I was like no more
Kardashians I'm willing to give up the
jokes yeah for the greater good yo yeah
thank you hi you know once in a while
aren't you like aching to talk about
Kim's feet though they keep showing
pictures of her know what's going on
super pregnant got tell you got ten
seconds I miss her feet are so swollen
because she's so pregnant and she keeps
wearing like these heels so she's
jamming her feet and they just keep
taking pictures of her feet all right
well I give you guys permission to pause
this for a second and Google Kim
Kardashian's feet because obviously it's
mocking of her but really what can we do
to help poor Amanda baby if we carry
practically started a kind of like
recovery group for online started bike
none of the none other than Courtney
Love yeah and now Alyssa Milano has
jumped on board and basically I think
they're gonna have some kind of
celebrity intervention Gary it'll get
really happening yes all right so Rianna
Alyssa Milano Courtney Love like do
these people really care about each
other or everyone's you're trying to get
their piece right
business like she is she needs to sign
herself into some whatever yeah facility
and that's the only way she's gonna get
help like you have to be wanting and
willing to get help that's what she she
keeps claiming she is allergic to drugs
and alcohol that's what she said yeah
and that she is the sponsor mental
illness have you ever met anyone that's
allergic to drugs or not what I don't
even know what that means yeah what how
does she know she's allergic to drugs
without having oh right thing no it
doesn't make sense that's like saying
I'm allergic to food I mean there's a
lot of different drugs you can't be
alert
you